>> Todd: ANOTHER DEMOCRAT
DIVIDE, CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ CALLING OUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN FOR NOT BLANKET
FOR PEOPLE MARIJUANA CONVICTION.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS NOT
TRIED IN TERMS OF LATINO
ELECTORATES.
WHERE'S OUR DREAM ACT.
WHERE IS OUR IMMIGRATION REFORM?
AND EVEN RECENTLY, WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S MARIJUANA
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
I VERY MUCH APPLAUD THAT HE WENT
THERE, BUT HE EXEMPTED PEOPLE
WHO WERE CONVICTED IF THEY WERE
CONVICTED WHILE THEY WERE
UNDOCUMENTED.
AINS.
>> Carley: FORMER ACTING DHS
SECRETARY CHAD WOLF.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
COMMENT FROM AOC?
>> I THINK IT JUST SHOWS HER
PRIORITY AND PERHAPS THE
PRIORITIES OF THE LEFT.
LOOK, THEIR IDEA OF SOLVING THIS
CRISIS AND SOLVING THE
IMMIGRATION CRISIS AND REALLY
TRYING TO APPEAL TO CERTAIN
VOTERS IS TO GIVE THEM BLANKET
AMNESTY OR IN THIS CASE
OBVIOUSLY DEALING WITH PARDONS
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
I THINK IT'S WRONG.
IT'S AN AMERICAN LAST STRATEGY.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT
TO SEE POLICIES FROM EITHER
PARTY.
IT'S REALLY IMPACTING AMERICANS
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND THIS ISN'T
IT.
>> Todd: ON THE MARIJUANA PART
OF THIS.
YOU HAVE HEARD LEGAL SCHOLARS
SAY NOBODY IS CONVICTED OF A
FEDERAL MARIJUANA POSSESSION
CRIME.
THAT IS LEFT TO THE STATES AND
LOCALITIES.
BIGGER PICTURE, ARE CHAD, AFTER
HIS APPROACH TO IMMIGRATION AND
THE BORDER IN TOTAL, WHY IS HE
PRETENDING TO PLAY TOUGH GUY
WITH THE ILLEGALS WHEN IT COMES
TO MARIJUANA?
>>
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
AGAIN, I THINK THIS IS THE
LEFT'S KIND OF APPEAL.
THEY BELIEVE THEIR APPEAL TO
LATINA VOTERS.
AND I THINK WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
THAT MOST LATINOS THAT WE HAVE
TALKED TO THAT I HAVE TALKED TO
WANT A SECURE BORDER.
THEY WANT FOLKS TO COME INTO THE
COUNTRY LEGALLY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE THOSE WHO
CAME HERE ILLEGALLY REWARDED
WITH PARDONS OR ANY OTHER TYPE
OF BEHAVIOR FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S THE WRONG APPROACH.
A MISREADING OF THAT COMMUNITY.
THEY WANT LAW AND ORDER.
THEY WANT PROCESS AT THAT
BORDER.
AND, YOU KNOW, AOC AND OTHERS
NEED TO BE FOCUSING ON SOLVING
THE CRISIS ON THAT BORDER.
WE HAVE HISTORIC CRISIS ON THAT
BORDER THAT THAT PARTY IS NOT
TALKING ABOUT AND IT'S A SHAME.
THEY ARE IN POWER.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO SOLVE
THIS TODAY IF THEY CHOOSE TO.
>> CHAD, MIGRANTS, INCLUDING
VENEZUELANS WHO HAVE BEEN SENT
BACK TO MEXICO HAVE NOW BUILDING
A TENT CITY ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE BORDER THEY ARE HOPING THIS
NEW BIDEN ADMINISTRATION POLICY
THAT SENDS VENEZUELANS BACK TO
MEXICO WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY IS GOING
TO EVENTUALLY GET OVERTURNED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOING THIS RIGHT
NOW?
SOME PEOPLE HAVE SAID THIS IS A
POSITIVE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
OTHERS SAY MAN O MAN THIS IS
JUST A DROP IN THE BUCKET.
>> WELL, I WOULD AGREE.
I THINK THIS IS TOO LITTLE TOO
LATE.
I THINK WHAT THEY ARE SEEING IS
THAT TEA TAKING AGAINST THE
VENEZUELANS PERHAPS COULD WORK.
IT'S JUST A SMALL YOU SAID DROP
IN THE BUCKET.
THE VENGZ IS JUST ONE POPULATION
COMING ACROSS THAT BORDER IN
HISTORIC NUMBERS.
AND SO IF THEY WANT TO GET
SERIOUS ABOUT IT.
THEY NEED TO NOT ONLY LOOK AT
VENEZUELANS BUT CUBANS AND ALL
THE OTHER NATIONALITIES, 130
NATIONALITIES COMING ACROSS THAT
BORDER.
THE NUMBERS THAT YOU ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO SEE OVER MONTH
AFTER MONTH AFTER MONTH EVEN
AFTER THIS POLICY HAS BEEN
INSTITUTED.
YOU WILL SEE THESE
ASTRONOMICALLY HIGH NUMBERS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAVE A
MATERIAL EFFECT OF WHAT IS GOING
ON AT THAT BORDER IS JUST GOING
TO EFFECT ONE SMALL POPULATION
SUCH AS THE VENEZUELANS, YOU
WILL SEE OTHER POPULATIONS AND
OTHER NUMBERS COMING ACROSS THAT
BORDER IN HISTORIC NUIVES THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SEE,
UNFORTUNATELY.
>> Todd: CHAD WOLF HAS A NEW
OP-ED ON FOXNEWS.COM.
AMERICANS DESERVE SOLUTIONS NOT
EXCUSES.
OF COURSE IT IS ON THE BORDER
CRISIS.
CHAD, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING